hey everybody welcome to an only look
into the beta of planet coaster now I
along with a couple of other content
creators got early acces into the beta
in order to make some sneak preview
videos of it and I was figuring for
quite a while of what I actually wanted
to do with this since the time frame I
have to be honest isn't quite large I
only had a couple of spare hours to put
this together before I really don't have
any time anymore and before the game
actually goes public so what I wanted to
do actually is focus on something other
than the coasters which are gonna be
super awesome
there are some great new rides some
great new scenery and great new
additions into the game but one thing
which actually wanted to focus on that I
don't think too many other people are
gonna pick up on are the detailing in
planet coaster the beta comes from what
I've seen with a lot of very small
pieces and a lot very small pieces that
you can recolor and put together in
different ways to make your own kind of
things and what for me is gonna make
this quite a game changer is that with
every new small piece that you get into
into the game the amount of things that
you can do pretty much exponentially
increase and with the new art pieces the
new very narrow pillars and wooden
brackets that kind of stuff in the game
you can actually do a lot to make your
own kind of details to give your own
kind of textures and make really your
own very detailed style of building and
this is what I think also the new beta
is gonna allow for a lot of different
styles and a lot more uniqueness to the
things that people are building so far
many of the builds in planet coaster
still refer back to the same objects
that everybody has there is not that
much free form when it comes to forming
your own balconies and making your own
windows or making your own anything on a
building really and I think the new very
small pieces are gonna be quite a game
changer in this and that's also why I
decided to build the style of building
that I'm building right here I wanted to
pick something very safe because I
didn't have time to blend this all so I
just kind of went
Oh No edit and decided to build a bit of
a French palace kind of stable building
inspired by those simple stable
buildings with an entrance maybe a
couple of towers a few simple
decorations kind of in the style of the
main palace that they're supposed to be
connected to which allows for a small
building but with loads of interesting
details and with the cool palace garden
around it and this is pretty much what I
wanted to settle for and what in the
case of very small details it allows me
to do is actually experiment a bit with
the details that you don't really see in
the game itself but that you can use the
new pieces for so for example the new
textile is art pieces can actually be
used to make your own anything really
but and there are a couple of pretty
small squares rectangles and triangular
and spherical pieces in there which is
so small and so versatile that you can
really make just about any anything out
of it so here I wanted to make a custom
cornice kind of in the style that fits
along with the rest of the building and
on the top of the roof there I also
wanted to put together those pieces to
make some fancy fences with lots of
fancy Peaks on the side as well to make
the building a little bit more
interesting and on the front here where
are we gonna have a small Tower with a
pretty simple spider but still what's
really the most defining feature of the
building I also wanted to play a bit
more with these very small new pieces
but um what I have to say is that before
I open the beta I was actually really
afraid that the new like texture loose
art pieces would not really fit with
building styles like many of the things
that frontier showed them off with and
what I suppose they're really meant for
is making any kind of like cartoony
decoration a thing for example they made
I think stuff like a dragon anything
that you can put together and make very
colorful and very carnival ish looking
but I was actually kind of afraid that
you wouldn't be able to use these pieces
to make custom building pieces and
insert them seamlessly into your
buildings but that's
something which this building sort of
proves otherwise
and that's what I was trying to do here
makes the the the the very free art
pieces together with the regular
building pieces and a mix the textures
and colors a bit make them stand out a
bit and create your own shapes that way
and especially for the cornices here
since I needed I needed some very flat
rectangular shapes and something that
blends into the rest of the scenery
these shapes were very useful for the
roof here I wanted to make a custom roof
and there are some there is a bunch of
new wooden pieces that are super handy
and this one is actually a very small
piece that almost makes this bit of a
roof texture to it if you put a lot of
them together I'm not actually that
worried about the amount of pieces here
the building is still well within the
two thousand pieces at the end not
causing any legs so far so I'm actually
quite happy with that and I'm here just
very quickly putting together the dormer
on the top of the spire here make the
building a bit more fancy I will take
over the top in a little bit but first I
am I wanted to decorate this sides a
little bit and this might just be me but
I'm actually really happy with how the
the very small new pieces as well as the
very narrow new pillars came out because
narrow pillars is something that the
game didn't really have yet but what I
think is actually gonna make quite quite
a big change for me at least since you
can make a lot out of these very narrow
beams you can just make supports out of
them but you can also make these a
victorian sort of galleries and front of
buildings you can make spires definitely
spires there were there's a lot of
pointy bits that you know the pieces
that we had so far were too large and
too bulky for that you can really get
into some more sophisticated smaller
details right now which is also why I
put a ridiculous amount of like as fiery
points on this building as well
and finally on top of the spire here I
wanted to put another pretty large
cornice to finish that off I wasn't
actually that happy with the shape of
the spire I just sort of tried it at
once to see how it would work out and I
wasn't that happy with it but i'm i
think the the top corners kind of shapes
the shapes out of the roof a little bit
more and i'm quite happy actually with
how that looks in the end there's a
bunch of new stuff for windows as well
the new windows are in a much more
generic style i think than the windows
that we had in the game so far which
were quite piratey quite costly and very
spanish or it's just completely modern
but now there are some windows which can
definitely be used in a lot of different
styles there's a lot of new windows and
door pieces that I quite like and over
here especially the dormers came in
pretty handy also I have to say this is
quite a Main Street looking building
even if it's a little bit more European
and many of these pieces can definitely
be made to make some very Disney asked
Main streets just something that I think
is very interesting and as one of the
lost parts of making the building I
wanted to get some dormers on the top of
the windows here just because that's
pretty much the only way to make this
roof a little bit more interesting most
of the detail in this building is really
in the roof I wanted to keep the walls
quite flat and have just all of these
different points and fences and
decorations on the roof and just to make
them come out a bit more I wanted to put
some dormers on them here as well which
are very simple I didn't want to take
time to really make these dormers too
interesting but um I'd least wanted to
get some dormers in there and these
quickly made dormers worked out pretty
nicely there
and finally it really comes down to the
detailing of the building to make it
come to life a bit and there's bunch of
new lanterns and stuff that you can hang
on the sides of balls and roofs and
that's why I quickly did there there's
also the robe which is supposed to be
used for the Western theme but it has a
French flag on it and I was like hey why
not might as well try it so I put that
on the balcony on the front and then the
last thing that I wanted to do which
isn't really related to the building
itself but really to making the building
look the way that it's gonna look in
some kind of context make the quick
simple Palace Gardens and I am not sure
if I really got this correctly but it
kind of seemed to me like the paths were
flowing a bit more easily though it's
probably just me I didn't actually try
it that much in lost alpha but I was
actually quite surprised in any case how
well the parts were doing with coming
together here and I think being able to
get the parts together to make some
actual larger plasters without curbs in
the middle an interesting new option in
the paths section is that you can
actually remove the kerb of a part which
is pretty cool because I actually didn't
quite like how if you put different
parts on the side of each other you have
curbs in the middle that was one of the
things that worked me about the pass
system but that's something that's a
thing of the past now which is quite
nice and also there are all of these new
textures which I'm really happy with
those and they are a lot more washed out
and generic and I think also a lot more
versatile than the part textures that we
had before so that's a very big
improvement and yeah especially in this
case since it has that old rustic brick
texture and the the gravelly Palace card
and texture it fits perfectly for what
I'm trying to go for here so there was
no reason not to use the new textures
for the pass here also of course I kinda
want to show them off as well now
finally I was struggling with these
lamps a bit as happy as I am with these
new lights because so far we didn't have
any
I like antique light posts yet the only
light post that we had was the modern
one and these look really good I was
trying to decorate them for a bit but
that didn't cover that well you can
always hang some planters on it or put
some extra Victorian decorations on them
but in this case I didn't have the
patience anymore and when it gets throw
it into the foliage because there are a
lot of new trees and I really like the
way that they look they're also a bit
more like that the colors are quite
different than what we had so far so far
many of the foliage items have very
similar colors which resulted in not
that very landscape when it comes to the
color of foliage but these the new trees
will definitely help make parks look a
lot more lush and I'm very happy with
that anyway that's just about it for
this time-lapse I hope you all enjoyed
and I hope you're looking forward to
seeing the beta it is awesome and I wish
you all a lot of fun with trying it